[Music]
once again this holiday season a
glorious christmas tree with over 7 000
lights grace's historic boston common
the tree itself is anything but local
though 50 years ago the canadian
province of nova scotia sent boston a
soaring evergreen and thanks for the
city's help after their capital of
halifax was devastated by a deadly
explosion
the tradition has continued every year
since
nancy chen shows us what it means for
both communities
[Applause]
about 40 miles outside halifax nova
scotia on the gourley's fifth generation
dairy farm a tree so tall it still holds
the lights strung some 20 christmases
past
having outgrown the family's highest
ladder long ago
we couldn't prune it anymore after that
we had to stop decorating because you
know
betty the girlies matriarch says the
white spruce has been growing right
alongside her family for nearly four
decades now this is rudolph and this is
dancer
but as a tree in waiting it's still a
few feet short from its eventual destiny
more than 600 miles away and across an
international border
chester gourley has been eagerly
anticipating his family's turn it's been
five or eight years since they said they
might consider us
it's something we've been waiting for
and
it's a big honor and a tradition dozens
of nova scotian families have performed
before them the spruce the province
sends each year becomes boston's
official christmas tree a gesture of
appreciation more than a hundred years
after the halifax explosion the largest
man-made explosion until hiroshima
happened here in the harbor
december 6
1917.
new glasgow's town crier james stewart
has accompanied the tree to boston in
past years during world war one and
halifax
was basically a hubbub of ships that
were getting ready to convoy across the
atlantic on the day of the explosion
that included the ss mont blanc on its
way to france when the ss emo crashed
into it in the narrowest part of the
harbor when the collision took place
sparks basically flew
and one of the ships had munitions on
the deck it was in a nutshell overloaded
just 20 minutes later as people gathered
to see what happened the ship erupted
the city was basically
flattened the north end of the city
two thousand people were killed and an
estimated 9 thousand people injured many
by shattering glass nearly 600 people
were treated for eye injuries to make
matters worse rescue efforts were
hampered by a blizzard blanketing the
region the next day stalling travel from
nearby major cities boston was the best
bet because it was a city that was big
enough close enough
and they dispatched the relief trains
based on a single plea for help by
telegraph medical teams from
massachusetts set out that night their
train making its way through the snow to
set up relief camps in the city what did
their arrival mean to the people of
halifax at the time it's
you know it's very much like the cavalry
arriving they brought halifax aid
when halifax needed it
the absolutely the most
and
it's something that's never been
forgotten
in large part because of customs like
this a grateful halifax delivered boston
a christmas tree the next year a gift
repeated in 1971 and every year since
what do you look for in the tree for
boston we look for a tree that's about
45 to 50 feet tall as manager of the
tree for boston program sandra johnston
considers contenders from across nova
scotia keeping an eye on about 15 trees
you have a list going essentially for
many christmases in the future yes we do
and i don't think i could sleep at night
if i didn't have a list of
trees coming up in the future trees are
nominated by the public as well as
landowners volunteering their own you're
sending your best and brightest to a
place that's pretty far away yes but you
know as most nova scotians love and
appreciate uh they remember the
assistance that boston gave us 104 years
ago and you don't have to go too far
when talking to anybody from nova scotia
to find that connection
a bond forged in tragedy now
commemorated each year as the tree makes
the long trip from nova scotia to boston
happy holidays boston enjoy your tree
it's on the way
communities line the truck's route with
sendoff parades as the journey overcomes
winter storms city traffic and even the
pandemic last year as land borders were
closed to non-essential goods the tree
traveled by container ship
a journey repeated this year
[Applause]
the 60-year-old tree from a cape
brighton non-profit cheered as it was
lit on the bus in common with the
premiere of nova scotia attending the
ceremony alongside boston mayor michelle
wu this is a symbol of what we can do
when we step up to see how we can be
there for each other so i'm incredibly
grateful to nova scotia for continuing
this important tradition a tradition the
gourley family is proud to partake in
one day the tree towering over their
front yard just a small token of
appreciation for the help from a far
away city so many years ago what does it
mean to you to have this tree
potentially go to boston well they
helped us
enormously and this is just a thank you
a community offering a helping hand when
it was most needed as gratitude endures
generations for cbs saturday morning
nancy chen halifax nova scotia